that looks like a total nightmare
yikes I don't think I can do it
really sure you can I think it would be
great a toddler and a stroller and
you're carrying one you can't have one
because he needs a friend you can't just
have two because they're not always
gonna get her along three at least two
we're always gonna be friends to be
honest I would be most comfortable with
four because then it's two against two
just stop come on it would be so fun I
need my sleep and not to be shallow but
think about it this it's great and this
hey come on
the dad bod is extraordinarily in right
now you would say that I want one no
matter what
Wow yep no that's not how it goes down
that is what getting old is you don't
get a dad bod it's called a dad Bob you
get mom jeans
all right just please promise me you
will never wear socks with sandals I
can't that is where we draw the line
that is literally the most comfortable
thing imaginable that's another thing
what happens when we become three we're
doing it say a command or say healthy
place song good morning I'll be honest
kids music is not the worst genre of
music there is you are gonna be like the
dad who's like yeah it's cool you're
always going away on stuff oh for sure
I'm gonna come in and they're gonna be
like mom said I couldn't do this I'll be
like what do you say though that is the
worst
you're gonna undermine me in front of
our kids what about spontaneous weekend
trip oh no no I think it's next to the
cell phone charger
oh well then I haven't seen it at all
yeah it's okay
so mate okay well then let's hit the
road
wait that's right you plan everything
down to the millisecond not that that's
bad I'm just saying
having a kid wouldn't change that I'd
probably be pretty good of parenting
actually yeah we would be pretty good at
parenting so you wanna get in the mood
with some sing-alongs oh no I just want
to pretend to be cool for like 15 more
minutes all right I'll just listen to
your piece
thank you very much